Learner A4: الو
Learner A4: اها.
Learner A6: الو إن شاء الله.
Learner A4: برافو.
Learner A6: بخير؟ الحمد الله.
Learner A4: الحمد لله معلش هو أنا مبارح كان عندي وجز وقت بلانينغ ويتينغ ما كنتش.
Learner A6: لا ولا يهمك.
Learner A4: ممكن تقوليلي أبديت سايد.
Learner A6: هو كل حوار اللي بعتوه على بعتتوا على الغروب
Learner A6: كل اللي حيبقى بيحصل حاليا إن إحنا نبقى بس على الحاجات اللي احنا عملناها خلاص و.
Learner A4: منقفل اللي احنا عملناه.
Learner A6: بالزبط يعتبر خلاص أنت تقريبا كان معاك الأساتذة صح؟
Learner A4: أنا للأسف.
Learner A6: بص على المفروض أنت تعملها إس بي جي او حاجة زي كدا تقريبا.
Learner A6: لا بس فأنت.
Learner A4: هو أنا بمشي عليه جروب يعني.
Learner A6: بالظبط الجروب بلاش دلوقتي تشوف ال برايفات عشان هم معاكو كتير قوي يا إما أقرأ كل اللي عال برايفات ويمشي على آخر حاجة هما قريانك عليها.
Learner A4: أنا عايز سراميك شريحة سوداء.
Learner A6: أياه.
Learner A4: أنا معرفش كان كان دقيق أوي ولا ولا هم نفسهم بس يوم كنت بسلم يما كنت بسلم يوم الرتو
Learner A4: قالولي اننا في حاجة ناقصة فهمتش.
Learner A6: مجانين ليش؟ لأنه.
Learner A1: بالتأكيد.
Learner A6: ا.
Learner A4: طب نحنا.
Learner A6: وما معيش.
Learner A4: ما خلصت.
Learner A6: بعدها يقول لي.
Learner A4: برضه.
Learner A6: طيب ما هو أنا حرفيا بعد.
Learner A4: هو إنتو هو إنتو برضه قالولكوا في حاجات ناقصة.
Learner A6: كل.
Learner A1: من.
Learner A6: تقول لي في.
Learner A1: وبعدين بعتلا.
Learner A6: مش.
Learner A1: مبدئيا أو أكثر.
Learner A4: نعم.
Learner A1: وبعد ذلك حتى لو تفتكر عمر انت عامل يو اي يقول لي ايوه رفعه.
Learner A6: وتخريب.
Learner A1: برضه.
Learner A6: دول على.
Learner A4: هو أصلا بيقولولي أنت ما عملتش كونفيرم مع مصطفى على حوار ال
Learner A4: الأسس والكلام ده واحنا عاملينو ولا حضرتك يعني في بول كوست
Learner A4: وحضرتك جوا الشغل الذي عملته بوش حطوا ديكومنتيشن كمان
Learner A4: حطوا في بيتهم وحطوا ديكوانتي قالولي لأ مش موجود يا جماعة إنت عارف إنت اللي هو إيه
Learner A4: عارف انت الهواء يعني أنا أنا عملته.
Learner A1: قل لي في ملف.
Learner A4: من هون ولا بس عندنا حلوة يعني ما تقولولناش بدري يا جماعة.
Learner A1: طب أنا مش فاهم.
Learner A4: عن هو
Learner A1: بغداد
Learner A1: طب احنا من المفروض القديم ولا.
Learner A4: هو.
Learner A6: بقى في الجديد اللي انبعت على الغروب شوفوا الأول انبعت من فرح عشان الباقي الا لو اتبعتلكوا آخر حاجة من ال أوي صح؟
Learner A6: لأن أنا حاليا إتبعتلي حاج فأنا شايف الفرح بعثته وبس.
Learner A4: هو بعد حاجة من 5 ساعات.
Learner A6: بيتأكد إن هي دي بيقولك.
Learner A4: أن لا
Learner A1: على.
Learner A4: فور دونيان
Learner A4: اس بي جي رايتر إيجينت
Learner A6: يبدو.
Learner A4: إيه الكلام دا بثوانا.
Learner A4: ديسك ثري هو كده.
Learner A6: لأ ما عشان كدا بقولك خش شوف اللي تبعت على المهندسة كارا. حسن.
Learner A4: لا هو بعد مش هي هي فرح قالتها على اللي بعد الساعة تناشر ولا الساعة حداشر إلا مبارح
Learner A4: ده هو بعد الساعة تنشر وربع الصبح النهاردة.
Learner A6: يبقى ممكن ده جديده.
Learner A1: وابعت لي حاجة أعمل حاجة على السوق ما كملتش.
Learner A6: لكن عايز نعمل يعني مش عارف اللي فجأة بيقولي اعملوا.
Learner A1: ما هو بينطالب مننا كدا برضو.
Learner A4: هو ما طلبش مني حاجة هو بيقوليش حاجة غلط الشورى.
Learner A1: أنا ما بحبش ما عملتش حاجة غلط.
Learner A4: حاجتين بيقولي أنت على التسويح اللي
Learner A4: وقالي لو اشتغلت عليها أكتر أقول لك كوتش كوتش ما اعرفش كوتش اللي حكلمه ده انتو.
Learner A1: فطار.
Learner A4: إزربي هو بيقولي ديدلاين بس معلش
Learner A4: إذا هو معلش تذكر وقلي انت
Learner A4: لأ هو علي إس بيجي رايتر بس.
Learner A6: جميل.
Learner A4: هو تقريبا بيقولي خش يبص على يعني هو بيقوليش مرق مش كتب مفضلة الرسام.
Learner A1: أحمد عيد آي وانت تو اس.
Learner A6: ده فرح بعتاه ولا اللي هم بعته.
Learner A1: كل 1. انا رقم سبعه.
Learner A6: بس.
Learner A4: بص على فكرة هو في حاجة مش مظبوطة على أنه
Learner A4: لا أصل سارة بعتهالي قبل ما الأحمد يبعتولي
Learner A4: بتقولي إيه الأغور. لو أنا ما أشتغل.
Learner A6: في.
Learner A1: في.
Learner A4: الصبح.
Learner A1: ما انا نفس الكلام. انا كنت انا في العسكرية برضه بتبعتلي وبتقولي مش عارف
Learner A1: ومش عارف اندي بوينت محتاجة تفصيل والإيو. آي كل واحدة متربطة بالاندبونت بتاعتها ازاي طب ما هو مش فاهم انا عملت ده كله.
Learner A4: أنت عارف المشكلة إن إنت مش متوقع إن ممكن يحصل أور من عندهم حتى بتشك في نفسك انت.
Learner A6: حرفيا.
Learner A1: التسليم.
Learner A6: كده عمال ارفع لهم نفس الحاجة وأروح أنا رحت.
Learner A1: يمر.
Learner A6: الكلام ده.
Learner A1: وبحط لك الكلام بتاعه يعني بحطله بقوله شوف امشي على
Learner A1: بيقول انا عملت كذا كذا وبقول لك يديني تقرير باللي انت عملتو عليها برضو كل.
Learner A4: معينه.
Learner A4: ما هو النقطة إنه أنا. شغال بودري في فرنش هو زي كولسوري يعني كرسر وكدا بس على اليونسكو،
Learner A4: فبقله ببعتلو بتاعهم يعني هو راسي يقول لي يا ابني احنا عاملين تاني.
Learner A1: ولا شي محترم.
Learner A4: عرفت لولا ما تقرفنيش أعملك تاني يعني.
Learner A1: اخترعلوا متى يعني أبتكرو تاني
Learner A1: جدي صعب.
Learner A4: هو غالبا غالبا كده التذكية يعني هو ما فيش حاجة مربوطة برايفات بس على قرط يبقى.
Learner A1: هي بتقولي أخش على سيرك ده بعد الغروبات.
Learner A4: لا مش قصدي هو برضه بتكلم على التذكية موجودة.
Learner A1: أه.
Learner A4: يعني تقريبا ماشية مع مع الفرح قالته أظن.
Learner A1: هو بموضوع الكوت ده يعني حاجة غريبة.
Learner A4: إيه الموضوع كل دا.
Learner A1: وأنا مثلا 1 دوكر يصير 1 اتش تيم ميل تو ام بور
Learner A1: الكلام ده حيبوظ الدنيا كلها العك ده كلو
Learner A1: يعني المفروض كل 1 حيسحب المشروع كله عنده عشان يعمل الكلام ده وهكذا يرفع تاني ولا يعمل
Learner A4: ، ما عنديش إجابة.
Learner A1: بس إنت درتها مثلا 1 يعمل تحسين 1 يعمل ثاني حيترجموا الفيديو ام بي فوق انا حعمل ليوزر أوسيبكيشن
Learner A1: المفروض كل 1 يعمل الجزئيه دي ويرفعها وبعد كده يعملها كلها ميرجي ثاني.
Learner A4: ما جرح.
Learner A3: أمور.
Learner A1: جروب.
Learner A3: انا عايز عمره عندي سؤال لي بس مشان عطلان عالي في الشغل الأخبار الأول عامل إيه.
Learner A4: الحمد لله انت تستاهل.
Learner A3: لا انا داخل من شوية وسمعنا تتكلموا عن الإيجنس
Learner A3: كنت اقول اريد ان اعرف منك انت عرفت فرح عايزه منك ولا لا.
Learner A4: أنا.
Learner A1: تتبع جروب.
Learner A3: تطلع.
Learner A4: 7 غروب ما هي كانت بقى الغروب وعطلة على.
Learner A3: يعني الذي يتعامل معنا ونرى بعد ذلك فخلينا مع الفرح الاول.
Learner A4: قرارات.
Learner A3: قصدك.
Learner A4: لو عايز تعرف ماشي ما هي موجودة.
Learner A3: لا أنا عارف كنت فاهم حضرت ال ريترو
Learner A3: شو إسمه الريتر ولا ده هارد بلانينغ،
Learner A3: فهي تكلمت انك ستعمل اس بي جي
Learner A3: عايز اعرف بقى انت بتشتغل بالإف بي جي بنود يعني انت حطلع الكوب بتاعك موديل ولا حتعمله ازاي وعايز اعرف اذا كنت انا طبعا شغال في سيمبلينغ فعايز. اعرف انت محتاج مني حاجة في ديسكريبشن
Learner A3: يعني محتاج ان اطلع لك الديسكريبشن يدخل في برومبت او حاجة اريد ان اعرف. انت محتاج مني بالضبط لكي تخرج بي جي كويس فاهمة قصدي لأنني سألتك قبل ذلك على إيه بتاعك
Learner A3: تحديدا من عندي في بلانت او انت شغال من عندي في بلان وللاسف يعني انا عارف اسامة انا لو اريد ان اعمل شغل جيد لأسامة، لكن انت بالنسبة لك مش عارف.
Learner A4: نعم.
Learner A3: مش عارف انت تستخدم.
Learner A4: أنا كنت بعتلك كنت بعتلك عشان تعرف.
Learner A3: نعم، انا فهمت كيف انت تستخدم ماذا بالضبط من ريبورت او تستخدم بلان بتاعتي وهو جزء لا اعرف
Learner A3: انت فاهم قصدي
Learner A3: انت بتهندل جزء يعني ممكن تقول لي انت بتهندل جزء بتاعك من بلان بتاعتي ازاي وتحطه في هانسمنت عليه ازاي يعني فاهم قصدي
Learner A3: بحيث ان انا برضو ببعد.
Learner A4: تعرف إنت عايز تعرف بيني وبينك صح.
Learner A3: اريد ان اعرف انت تاخذ مني بالزبط واقدر اعمل تحسينات ويعمل به؟ كيف لا اعوضك الدنيا لو عملت تحسينات لا تبقاش بعيد عن عملي.
Learner A4: صنيعة.
Learner A3: براحتك عادي يعني حتى.
Learner A4: لا، لا بسأل بسأل يقول لي مشهد قلبي مهوش.
Learner A3: انا بطلع حاجات انت لو تريد بشكل معين اكثر لو تريده بشكل مفصل اكثر، ليس لدي مشكله. اضبطها
Learner A3: انت ممكن ايضا تسال نفس السؤالينجكريبشن مثلا او هكذا الفيلد الذي انت تشتغل عليه وتحسينه يكون افضل
Learner A3: وانا ممكن اخذ منك.
Learner A4: اللي بيني وبينك هو مافيش حدش في مستوى تاني معانا صح انت بس أتأكد مصطفى بس.
Learner A3: أه هو أنا بشتغل.
Learner A4: طيب
Learner A4: انت عايز تعرف مودر ولا لا صح
Learner A4: بعتلك الحاجة السبت
Learner A4: الله نعم تروح
Learner A4: شكرا
Learner A4: مصطفى
Learner A4: مصطفى.
Learner A3: معك يا عمر.
Learner A4: بص انا بعتلك دلوقتي فكك أبص عليها برضه لو عايز.
Learner A3: على.
Learner A3: معلش أستأذنك بعد كده ببعض على فكرة عشان الحاجات اللي تبقى منا تفضل إيش موجودة.
Learner A4: هبعتلك على السلك اللي هنا الحاجة حتروح.
Learner A3: بالضبط.
Learner A4: طب بص طب أنا معك قلي في حاجة ثانية عايز تسألها عشان ابعتهالك
Learner A4: خلتو يسأل وايز.
Learner A4: شكرا.
Learner A3: ألورز ماشي بس ثانية وحدة هارد.
Learner A4: ماشي ماشي.
Learner A3: كويس جدا يا عمر بالعكس.
Learner A4: معلش. أنا مش سامعك.
Learner A3: اريد ان اعرف كيف يعني.
Learner A4: من.
Learner A3: اللي بتعملوا على.
Learner A4: مصطفى.
Learner A4: أنت.
Learner A3: اذا انت سامعني يا عمر.
Learner A4: تكمن.
Learner A3: عمر بكلمك.
Learner A4: صوتك مبتوم.
Learner A3: فوزي مكتوم.
Learner A4: هو انت قبل ما تقفل المايك معرفتش اللي حصل.
Learner A3: في الشارع.
Learner A4: طب قولي
Learner A4: معاك طبعا
Learner A4: انا مش فاهم الكلمة اللي انت كاتبها
Learner A4: والشرب الآخر من فضلك
Learner A4: حكتبلك احسن كده فهمت الشرعي. طيب تمام
Learner A4: طب عايز مني حاجة ثانية ولا تمام كده
Learner A4: شيء ثاني ولا صحيح؟
Learner A4: لا والله بتنزل طيب ثانية واحدة
Learner A4: أبعتلك على سيركل
Learner A4: إمم جميل
Learner A4: ماشي خلاص.
Learner A3: عمر.
Learner A4: معك.
Learner A3: طيب اقول لك انا هكذا عرفت الدنيا تمشي كيف
Learner A3: احسن الموضوع قليلا وبعدها نجربه سويا.
Learner A4: ماشي أنا بقدر اشوف شرفاء هو الكلام الموجود على عامة يكون فيم الفرح.
Learner A3: ما هي ارتيبو بتكتب فرح التصكات عليها فيما عدا ذلك.
Learner A3: شوية حاجات إضافية. من شوية حاجات إضافية من فرح مش عارف لكن الأساسي هو على تيبل والاساسي اللي بيتقال في بلانينغ.
Learner A4: تمام للأسف ماهرش احضر.
Learner A3: مش مشكلة ما أنا قلتلك ولقيتك عارف يعني طيب فرح تكتب عليه
Learner A3: انت خلي مرجعك ما تروحش نفسك مع ال إيجنس.
Learner A4: هم عامة.
Learner A3: أهلا بك.
Learner A4: على.
Learner A4: واو منور.
Learner A4: الجمهور تأخر شوي.
Learner A3: عمر باشا.
Learner A4: لا.
Learner A3: بارك الله فيك.
Learner A4: الأزرق.
Learner A4: محدش. قال حاجة يعني ما فتاكش حاجة وكدا.
Learner A4: لك.
Learner A4: بس مصطفى كان بيسألني أنا ماشي وبهني الشغل اللي هو بيبعتوله إزاي بس الباقي أصلا ما قالش أي حاجة.
Learner A4: داخل ولا مين.
Learner A4: كان أسامة اللي داخل الثالث بتاعك ولا مين.
Learner A4: كان أسامة. وكان في أحمد عيد الصنف أول شي.
Learner A4: تقريبا إحنا الأربعة.
Learner A4: هو فيلم يعني في.
Learner A4: مش عارف والله والله.
Learner A4: يعني في ناس ما دخلتش معانا من الأول خالص.
Learner A4: عادي.
Learner A4: أي ميتين مصطفى بيك.
Learner A4: في ناس بتخش في الأول وتخلق
Learner A4: 5 دقايق سجلتوا حضور وخلاص السلام عليكم.
Learner A4: هو انت قالولك لما جيت تسلم قالولك في حاجات ناقصة.
Learner A4: يا عم دول العالم يا عم بجد صعبت قوي بجد
Learner A4: يعني الأدمن لازم يفضل مشاك عليهم الله يعينوا بصراحة.
Learner A4: أنا.
Learner A4: من.
Learner A4: قعدت في قاعة الجمعة والسبت بحاول أفهم هو المشكلة فين ولله.
Learner A4: يمين.
Learner A4: بس.
Learner A4: المشكلة بصرة نادر قالت لي خلاص انت الديد لاين قرب ولازم تقولي ومعرفش وتعرفني الدنيا ازاي
Learner A4: بصي على احمد منصور احمد منصور قال لي انا اكلم شغل والمنتور قالتلي أنا ماليش دعوة
Learner A4: وبعد كده فجأة كده فرح لسا مش براجع كوم.
Learner A4: بعد من حيث لا أحتسب
Learner A4: لقيت احمد منصور بعتلي قال لي الله عليك يا فنان انت خلصت السترانتات بتاعت ووعد يطبل شوية.
Learner A4: وكذلك.
Learner A4: ما قص.
Learner A4: أنا أنا ما فهمتش بقى بعد كده قلت خلاص هو تقريبا مقموصين مني عشان بكلمهم يعني انت شايف مثلا.
Learner A4: على.
Learner A4: ربنا يخليك.
Learner A4: ما قلك شي هاي نائصة.
Learner A4: وصار أنا مقتنع إن أنا ما سلمتش حاجة.
Learner A4: هو النقطة في حاجة والنقطة إن سارة بتقولي في حاجة ناقصة
Learner A4: هو المفروض هو اصلا الديكومنتيشن اللي هو الحاجات اللي أنا أوصفها عملنا عليها. أبروف مع مصطفى الحاجات دي.
Learner A4: أيوة صح؟ انت عملت إيه في الحوار ده.
Learner A4: ما هي النقطة اللي أنا عملته
Learner A4: ما بعثت مصطفى وقال لي صور شكلها تمام وكل حاجة وأنا عامل دي كومنتيشن يعني خلاص.
Learner A4: خلصت خلصت.
Learner A4: ما كنت مخلص هي النقطة بحاجة.
Learner A4: يا كمل.
Learner A4: ما
Learner A4: النقطه ان هو هم مقتنعين انه انا ما خلصت يعني ما خلصتش وأنا خلصت وحط في ديسكريبشن في بول كوست
Learner A4: ده بتاع ووضعوا إندي فايف ايضا في الذي أعمل
Learner A4: يا جدعان والله عملته لو انا بقول لي كذا بيقوليك اياه فهمت.
Learner A4: ده حرفين اللي أنا كنت فيه.
Learner A4: لقيت احمد بيقول لي إيه انت
Learner A4: على فكرة بتقول الكلام ده ساعة بعدت بحاول يقول لي انت كده
Learner A4: عندك فرصة لحد يوم تنين ثواني
Learner A4: بعد كده قال لي تسكت قفل التسكتملها مع الاستنتاجات يا جماعة مسلم.
Learner A4: آمال.
Learner A4: أم.
Learner A4: نفس الحوار بس ده شو عندهم يعني كلمت محمد خاتم قال لي لا ده وهو بزبط
Learner A4: بصراحه ازبطها يعني الحمد لله احمد منصور.
Learner A4: بعد الصبح من بعد.
Learner A4: بغض النظر عن طريقته معايا في يوزراند أور ويل بي موف في في.
Learner A4: مش فاهم يعني إحنا عايزين ناخذ.
Learner A4: لا.
Learner A4: الهند، نحتل الكويت.
Learner A4: المهم طيب انت عرفت إيه اللي حصل مبارح؟ نعم.
Learner A4: مصطفى قالي امشي على الفرح وتعادل على الشركة.
Learner A4: مقطوع الإرث.
Learner A4: ماشي حلوة.
Learner A3: لا إمشي على.
Learner A3: على.
Learner A3: ما.
Learner A4: طيب إهدأ.
Learner A3: إذا.
Learner A4: ما أنا قلت ما أنا قلت.
Learner A4: ما أنا قلت مأنا قلت اللي على قولت
Learner A3: انت على تيركل مع.
Learner A4: المفروض تمشي اللي على.
Learner A3: ماشي ما هو اللي على الحكومة على.
Learner A4: هو نفس.
Learner A3: تعديلات أو حاجات إضافية.
Learner A3: ميشيل عون قال.
Learner A4: أنا ما هو الكلام اللي على مكتوب على على.
Learner A3: سيرك طيب.
Mentor A: بينها.
Learner A3: تمام.
Mentor A: هلا هلا.
Learner A4: أيوة بالمرة أيوة تفضلي.
Mentor A: إمم.
Learner A4: تفضل يا أهلا وسهلا.
Mentor A: أنا قلتلكم مبارح إن هو أنا التذكرات مبارح بعتلكم مسج كبيرة كده على الشركة.
Learner A4: من.
Mentor A: في بوك في ال سيستم هو يعني خد تاسك وحدة حطها الكل في ارتيبل
Mentor A: فاهمين فعشان كده بعتلكوا المسج وقلتلكوا امشوا على دي لحد ما تبقى ريزول هي دلوقتي ريزولف بتاعت هي دلوقتي.
Learner A4: عبد.
Mentor A: العادي هو هو اللي موجود في المسج بس لو حد كان بص عليها قبل مبارح قبل المسج اللي حبعتها
Mentor A: كده هو اشتغل في حاجة مش.
Learner A4: أنا لقيت احمد لقيتي حاجة ولقيت حاجة ثالثة خالص.
Mentor A: بعتتلكوا حاجات جديدة بعد مسج الصبح النهارده تاني.
Learner A4: أحمد منصور بعد.
Mentor A: ما.
Learner A4: وأحمد اللي بعد.
Mentor A: مش.
Learner A4: الاثنين 1.
Mentor A: هي نفس يعني
Mentor A: وكده كده أنا اعتمدت إن إحنا تكلمنا في ميتينغ وكل 1 عارف هو عايز يعني هيعمل
Mentor A: فقلت أنا مش إيش لو هي في برج وقبل مش مضبوط دلوقتي و ماسجر
Mentor A: بس فتشك تاني كده وكده المفروض كل 1 يعرف هيعمل هدية واضحة يعني.
Learner A4: تمام ماشي لو ينفع بس يعني.
Mentor A: ماشي أنا مش عارفة مين اللعب
Mentor A: كده كده هو كده كده ده بيكونتندس ده فا.
Learner A4: وصلنا خالص.
Mentor A: أسامة.
Learner A4: يعني هو في ناس يا إما بتخش
Learner A4: يا إما بتخش 5 دقايق وتطلع.
Mentor A: أسامة. طيب.
Mentor A: اسامة
Learner A4: أسامة. أنا علشان داخل متأخر، فهو كان موجود.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: حاجة.
Learner A4: هو لو تاخدي بالك يعني معلمة مين في.
Learner A4: قلي بس عم نعمل مبارح.
Learner A4: يعتبروا 4 هم اللي في 2 بس بقول لك من حيث يعني كلامك معانا من الاربعه بس
Learner A4: او اللي بنتكلم على.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: بس أنا شايف في موفر.
Mentor A: هو كذا كذا يعني كذا كذا يعني هو تقريبا اللي فضل 2 بس أم
Mentor A: هو في تلاتة في 3 غير إنتو إنتو وأسامة ماشي في يوسف و ومهدي.
Learner A4: وأحمدش مين.
Mentor A: قصدي مش قصدي قصدي إنتو اللي إحنا أكتر حاجة إنتو أسامة
Mentor A: التلاتة التانيين بقى هو أحمد ويوسف و ومين تاني ومهدي تقريبا صح.
Learner A4: ما عندي.
Mentor A: عمي مهدي هو التذكرة بتاعته سافرت ملهاش علاقة بالكو فكده كدا يعني هو ده بالنسبة لو عملوه مشي.
Learner A4: أم.
Mentor A: يوسف مش إنتو أونلاين عليها سوا وإنتو عليها دي برضه مالهاش حاجة يعني
Mentor A: هو سبرت عنكو شوية أديلو بس اتش تيم، قل وهو يشوف كدة. كدة أنا فهمت.
Learner A4: أنا أنا عملت كوش وحطيت اللينك بتاع البرنس وتكلمت معايا وقلت له في حاجة أنا معاك.
Mentor A: خلاص فاضل أحمد أحمد الصراحة هو مش إنبورت أوي في البورت براين آي دون مواصلة.
Learner A4: كلنا في.
Mentor A: في.
Learner A4: داوي.
Mentor A: ماشي هو في سبرنت أصلا وقعت منه
Mentor A: ما أسلمش الحاجة بتاعتها وكذا المهم هو برضو التاسكت بتاعته يعني بيور بيور سوفتويرز ديفيلوبمينت يعني أنا عايزة بس
Mentor A: الموجود ليه فوق ال باك اند والفرغين بس.
Learner A4: أوكي.
Mentor A: لا أنا قصدي يعني إنتو المين الكور قلت لكم في الكور هو إنتو عشان يطلع الحاجة غسيل
Mentor A: يعني مش عارفة يعني هو دايما ما بيدخلوش مش عارفة الصراحة حبقى أخلي أحمد منصور يبعث لهم
Mentor A: يأكد على الموضوع ده.
Learner A4: ما.
Mentor A: طيب خلاص كملوا.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A4: يس.
Learner A4: كم مطلب لما كان موجود؟ اقل حاجة.
Learner A4: أو هم كانوا بيقولولي إنتو إنتو مبارح.
Learner A4: طيب ماشي طيب انت شفت حوري الاسم ده.
Learner A4: تفتح وري الإسم دي ولا لسه تبدأ في.
Learner A4: ما أنا لسا بقولها هيدي. أنا أصلا مبارح كان عندي كويز عشان كويس.
Learner A4: الله يعينك الله يعينك عمر.
Learner A4: وعندي تسليمات يوم الخميس.
Learner A4: خلصت عمر عايط معاك يا أختي.
Learner A4: لا، لا والله مش قصدي حاجة.
Learner A4: عارف طيب ماشي بالنسبة حغلصه النهارده وهبعته ده بالنسبة لي مختص
Learner A4: وبالنسبة لك انت بالله عليك في عمر حاول ترن بروديت كله وشوف الاسيت اللي طالعة.
Learner A4: المشكلة.
Learner A4: أو.
Learner A4: قبل الريترو.
Learner A4: حلو.
Learner A4: بيجيب لي قرص فأنا هو بيقرر من سيست تو معايا.
Learner A4: طب انت عملت مرج للبرنش. اللي أنا بعته آخر حاجة عملتلكوا عليه.
Learner A4: أنا ما عملتش مرجم في الإسبرانتا الاخيرة.
Learner A4: اصلا بقى طب بص.
Learner A4: لا يعني بعد ما عملتش مرش بس.
Learner A4: مش.
Learner A4: فني أبرود ساعتها حصل.
Learner A4: لا لا مش بقولك إنت اللي تعمل عم بقلك خود ده ماشي اضغط اضغط على
Learner A4: بتاع اللي انا بعتهولك حيطلعلك المسج خش على اللينك بتاع البرنس ده واعملوا ميرج عندك ده المفروض اللي هي.
Learner A4: في تمام ده المفروض ال بروجكت والفايبلين واللي واي كله شغال فيه زي الفل عادي ما فيش أي مشكلة.
Learner A4: و.
Learner A4: لا ما تعملش دلوقتي مرجع لمين خالص.
Learner A4: لأ مش قصدي. أنا قصدي ما خدش فيلمين عندي.
Learner A4: ما هو أنا مش عارف الين آخر مرة كان مش عارف من امتى استنى أدي المين بريند
Learner A4: آخر حاجة من الأسبوع اللي فات ده كان إيه في الوكالة سمن
Learner A4: كان مين اللي عامله كان كان اسامه كان اتشيميل جينيراشن
Learner A4: حتى يعني قبل حتى اخر حاجة اوصلها
Learner A4: هو ال مين بس كاركتير كمان بس ك آخر فيتشر إحنا عاملينها ولدت
Learner A4: فخذ الينك. اللي انا بعتهولك ده المفروض في آخر اسامة عملها يعني ده المفروض اللي انت تبدأ بيه بتاعة الاسبوع ده.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A4: عندي مع الكود اللي أنا عملتو صح.
Learner A4: لا انت يعني مش مش فاهم يعني.
Learner A4: يعني أخذ الشغل اخر حاجة انتو عاملينها عندي رقم.
Learner A4: مش.
Learner A4: حاجة عن مين أو على برنس أو على.
Learner A4: عايز تعمل براحتك بس ما طلبش من لمين دلوقت.
Learner A4: أنا قصدي انتو مش عايزين الشغل دلوقتي لسه لما خلصت.
Learner A4: إحنا.
Learner A4: واخد الشغل. تمام.
Learner A4: اللي انت عملتها. طيب.
Learner A4: هو مش قصدي قوي مصطفى عالفريجوالز.
Learner A4: طيب خذ.
Learner A4: مفهوم مصطفى كان بيفهم مين اللي
Learner A4: إزاي وكده عشان يعرف يكمل هو.
Learner A4: تمام ماشي خذ ال خود ال برانش اللي أنا بعته خذ ال
Learner A4: وشوف في يعني مثلا لو إيماجيز متعددة شوف أنهي فايل أحسن
Learner A4: اللي أنا عدلت عليه ولا الفايل اللي معاك
Learner A4: هو كده المفروض ال تتغير كلها للاسف كل كل من ناحيتها هتتغير
Learner A4: لان انت المفروض هتشتغل اف بي جي وكمان انت عندك في البرانش ده فخذه اشتغل عليه
Learner A4: وممكن تعمل برنش فين يعني تفكك من برنش اللي انت فيه دلوقتي ده
Learner A4: تعمل برنش ثاني وتعمل ميرج باللي أنا لسه بعته ده بحيث إن آخر حاجة إنت كنت عملها مع نفسك
Learner A4: ما يحصلهاش أي حاجة من الجديدة فاهم
Learner A4: معايا ولا مع الأسف ولا انت فين.
Learner A4: معاك.
Learner A4: أيوه.
Learner A4: معك مشروع.
Learner A4: ماشي؟ ولا ابدأ من أول وجديد.
Learner A4: نعم.
Learner A4: بيرس عم برجع يعني فهمت حتة بتاع برنش اللي انت بعته.
Learner A4: أقولك على حاجة حلوة.
Learner A4: انت شايف ال آخر حاجات انت عملتها.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: اعملكم شغال عليه تمام.
Learner A4: أنا ألريدي أعمل كومبتر جديد.
Learner A4: حلو اعمل برنش جديد بإسم ال اف بي جي
Learner A4: أي حاجة بقى لها علاقة بتعتك حلو.
Learner A4: اعمل ميرز بالبرانش بتاعي.
Learner A4: ميش.
Learner A4: تمام كده.
Learner A4: تمام هو انت لقيت رأي.
Learner A3: محتاجين مني حاجة ولا ينفع عصير.
Learner A4: أسمع.
Learner A3: فرنج.
Learner A4: انت تيست بتاعتك تمام صح مش محتاج حاجة، صح؟
Learner A4: مصر.
Learner A4: مصطفى.
Learner A4: واخا مشي تقريبا.
Learner A4: ماشي ماشي هو لسا موجود بس هو تقريبا ايمتى دلوقتي قصدي.
Learner A4: ماشي انت بتقولي في وايه تاني تغيرت ولا هو كل 1 فينا مختلف عادي.
Learner A4: تاني يشتغل بقى لما فاتحلك المدن بتاعت كلها؟
Learner A4: ألريدي أنا عامل فايل اسمه موديل
Learner A4: اول ما انت تاخده عندك المفروض كل حاجة تبقى ماشية تمام يعني.
Learner A4: أوه، أنا وأنا أنا عندي قناع عملوا ده بورت وعامل يعني وعندي جيمرايا تنين.
Learner A4: اقولك على حاجة احسن. احسن.
Learner A4: حصل أي دروب.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: 5.
Learner A4: لو لو حاجة مهمة او كده ما رديتش اتصل عليا عادي.
Learner A4: طيب أنا كنت داخل عشان أعرف أنتو عملتوا إيه مبارح وكدا كدا
Learner A4: يعني باخد ال ديسكو من على سواء يعني.
Learner A4: أحمد منصور.
Learner A4: وبتعامل انا مع الايش انت اللي شاغل بيها.
Learner A4: ماشي أنا بس علشان بس علشان بس الفيديو عشان في الفيديو أو عامة في كويسة أوي
Learner A4: فهي دي بس النقطة الوحيدة شوف كدا ومع بعض.
Learner A4: طيب خلاص.
Learner A4: تمام نخلع كده خلاص.
Learner A4: بارك الله فيك.
Learner A4: 20 أو شي.
Learner A4: لا أنا كنت بس كنت يعني كان إحنا كان يعني الكلام ده تاع مبارح كان بس.
Learner A4: يعني.
Learner A4: عرفت خلاص
Learner A4: خلاص.
Learner A4: يس.
Learner A4: ماشي بس ربنا معاك والله.
Learner A4: حبيبي.
Learner A4: والله أمر مؤسف.
Learner A4: خليك.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: ماشي حبيبي إنت مش عايز حاجة طيب.
Learner A4: لم تمام.
Learner A4: الله يخليك.
Learner A4: إن شاء الله.
Learner A4: باي واي.